j'accueille marc toesca
[Musique]
saluée bonsoir des petits clowns nous
sommes mercredi et comme vous le savez
le mercredi est consacrée au top 30 au
top des albums des cassettes et des
compacts et dans cette semaine réservée
exclusivement aux must de l'année 1987
je vais vous révéler dans quelques
instants
le top du top du top 30 le top des tops
des albums des cassettes et des
compactes un top 30 qui a démarré le 18
mars 1987
regardez bien ce sont les trente albums
de l'année
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
marc toesca sur son lieu de travail à
monaco sous le soleil mais c'est vrai
que pour aller au bout l'ont fait quand
même déjà plus agréable
c'est mieux que perry
l'ancien animateur du top 50 a monté sa
propre maison de disques est désormais
son horizon professionnel
il le regarde avec vue sur mer la mer
c'est
c'est vital mais la mer les dans mes
gènes donc chez pull besoin de le
regarder à moi j'y croyais au programme
yugo niant en yeux relève après avoir
été le monsieur classement des ventes
marc toesca souhaite aujourd'hui lancé
des artistes y
pharmacie automobile club and live at
the twenty five c'est koh lanta leurs
trucs et l'on estime ce matin il a
justement rendez vous avec un groupe
anglais de hip hop qui se souvient
parfaitement du top 50
on peut bosser là ou bien la concurrence
est rude et marc tient à conserver ses
secrets de fabrication
[Musique]
tous les midis à l'heure où monaco
bouillonne d'activité marc toesca fans
de triathlon fait du jogging en
compagnie d'un ami pour le moins
connaisseurs présente laurent urbain
fait partie de l'organisation du
triathlon de monaco et
c'est un pack aux lycées de lui si j'ai
repris la course à pied c'est un enfer
de courir avec lui comme je trouve un
petit peu plus vite
des fois quand ils échangent le lâche
voilà voilà
on appelle ça les amis
marc a maintenant rendez vous au
prestigieux opéra garnier de monte carlo
il y retrouve l'un de ses artistes
l'entrée des arts twist mac os va se
produire ce soir en première partie de
pete doherty
vous avez vu le planning à peu près
comme ça on n'a pas à ce jour jamais
affiché est donc 18 à 30 ans et ça lui
chante et chacun sa croix
voilà
l'opéra garnier est beaucoup plus
impressionnant que le plateau du top 50
mais marc toesca aide ici comme celle
qu'ils ont terminé et ça pose pas de
problème lui comme sa manière et la
radio ont été vus avec une équipe
ouais c'est bon si on fait moins
commandant ouais ouais super je
cherchais bataille pour moi oui j'ai
toujours un peu la pression parce que
pour moi j'ai jamais le trac
j'ai vraiment jamais connu le trac mais
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui j'ai le trac
pour mes artistes qu'on veut rentrer
dans une salle comme ça et on prend pas
la gâcher mais comment ils vont faire
quoi en fait
et puis voilà ça se passe bien
mais c'est génial
[Musique]
oh
un autre de luxadvor 1 on est bon pour
toi
les répétitions sont également
l'occasion pour marc de nous montrer ce
qu'il a au bout des doigts la musique
qui lui trotte dans la tête et avons le
de se faire plaisir
quelques heures avant le début de la
représentation marqué son artistes sont
attendus sur l'antenne d'une radio
locale pour annoncer le concert de ce
soir
le producteur est sur un nuage je me
grattais l'antenne c'était marqué
silence excusez moi
habitué des studios radio c'est
également comme spécialiste de la
musique que marc intervient ce soir
juste un truc pour pour finir la réponse
à nicolas
je crois que on n'a jamais autant
consommé de musique qu'aujourd'hui que
ce soit
différemment dans la consomment
différemment n'en a jamais écoutés voilà
il y en a partout
j'éprouve un jeu vidéo c'est pour la
télé tu prends la radio tu prends tout
sur la musique partout bien sivakova
mercedes a ses chances merci à vous et
merci merci nous avoir aussi c'est
vraiment sympa
les p'tits clous sont mélangés
souhaitons lui que ses productions
musicales occupent les premières places
du top 50
à m et maintenant la lumière se rallume
sur marc toesca bienvenue son plateau de
tout le monde a parlé alors vous êtes né
le 20 octobre 1955 à nice où vous
grandir et votre père était conseiller
clientèle pour une marque de voiture
française laquelle peugeot et votre mère
vendait des parfums ou aux galeries
lafayette à nice l'enjeu est d'abord
scolarisés à l'école communale du
château puis au lycée segura mais roland
garros
tout jeune déjà vous êtes passionné de
musique et votre argent de poche vous
sert à acheter des disques
le premier vous avez acheté c'est
l'expert de nike tou gabart des stones à
9 ans pas mal
j'avais entendu ça un dimanche chez des
amis de mes parents chez qui on avait
été déjeuner il y avait des grandes
filles qui avait 17 18 ans donc des
vieilles pour moi et qu'ils écoutent et
ce truc en boucle et j'adorais surtout
la face b vos buts chose et voilà alors
retrouvé contact avec les médias c'est
la création d'une radio pirate juste
après la frontière avec l'italie à
bandoulière les émetteurs sont tournés
vers la france c'est radio continental
qui aimait de menton à cassis en haut
c'était vraiment une radio pirate
puisqu'on a failli tout finit en prison
mais bon c'est un peu comme radio
caroline c'est un peu comme un lieu
caroline et vos potes vous demande de
venir faire la programmation parce que
vous avez une collection de disques
plaignant d'une ère mais mieux il se
terminera très mal puisque le matériel
sera saisie par la police
bah oui parce qu'en plus à l'époque il
ya un flou artistique sur sur les
législations des radios fm en français
du pas des fermes on avait trois radios
ou non vers 4 inter europe 1 rtl
et rmc et dans le sud on recevait que
rmc est un petit peu inter donc il y
avait il y avait un flou juridique
donc rien ne nous interdisait de prendre
une radio italienne et de diffuser en
français mais le jour on a commencé à
piquer des auditeurs notamment à radio
monte carlo
on a été bipé puis on a été cette
expérience qui vous fait remarquer par
rnc vous participer à un concours
d'animateur parce qu'à l'époque avait
des concours d'animateur présentée par
jean pierre foucault et voilà et vous
commencez donc à rmc côte d'azur ouais
bah c'est à dire que ce qu'on faisait
sur la radio fm en italie on nous a dit
on nous a demandé de le faire sur rmc
dire que rmc a créé une vraie fait mais
on était une bande de jeunes loups à la
montée cette radio dans la bande y avait
question board moustiques avait chabat
voilà quoi
belle écurie à la rame en plus tard on
vous entend sur les grandes ondes dans
disco clad effectivement c'est la grande
époque des drm c'est avec jean pierre
foucault et puis pierre lescure
directeur des programmes il y avait
aussi un albert mathieu qui pouvait le
responsable de projet de la can après
qu'ils étaient canal aussi alors voilà
qu'en lescure par créer canal + sa part
il emmène vous chabat christian borde
alias jules edouard moustic et vous vous
prenez la présentation du top 50 en 1984
le premier top 50 c'est de 4 novembre
1984 et le premier numéro un c'était
sympa peter et sloane ah [ __ ]
oui comme tu dis c'était la grande
surprise n'oubliera non c'est
inoubliable surtout parce qu'à l'époque
bon canal c'était de greef laisse qu
enfin les mâles qui ont créé les enfants
du rock
ils se sont retrouvés unis avec une
émission quotidienne qui va sonner du
moniteur à six longueurs de sa démission
les causes bien le faire chier parce que
je pense que ça les faisait bien marrer
aussi pas à l'époque avait encore deux
classements puis encore gros show et
chico sur antenne 2 et puis en fait
voilà le top 50 est vite devenu la
référence pour les meilleurs sans
respect
tout ça au coeur des débuts de canal
tout est à inventer et vous inventez des
tas de trucs quoi ces bouts de ficelle
cinq ans tu regarde des émissions le top
au tout début
en fait c'est une émission de radio avec
des caméras fixes on veut on veut toute
l'équipe du top
venez de la radio moi j'arrivais de la
radio j'ai fait je n'avais jamais fait
de télé avant les mecs le réalisateur
voulait leur envie de vieilles venait
d'un radio il était réalisateur de de
gildas je crois à l'époque des matinales
les cadreurs avait fait des stages de
réinsertion pour être cadreur le
l'éclairagiste pareil devait être au
garage il a fait un stage est devenu
éclairagiste donc on était une bande de
mecs qui arrivait de la radio on a eu
tout de suite le langage radio et quand
tu écoutais jingle et remonte à l'ailé
les virgules sonore voilà une émission
de radio koi
moi j'avais vingt secondes pour
m'exprimer pas plus voilà à vous dites
on faisait pas de la télé on faisait
canal+ c'était un langage différent
c'était des gens différents même les
gens de même été humainement c'était
c'est un autre monde quoi vraiment vraie
évolution alors avec vos chemises à
fleurs improbable et votre célèbre
slogan salut les p'tits clous
vous devenez une star alors qu'il faut
dire c'est que les petits tout ça parce
que les gens écrivent et marc toesca
d'où les petits clous c'est idiot
ces benêts mais c'est resté dans c est
quand même encore exactement ce monde
s'en souvient en pareil c'est une marque
déposée aussi parce qu'un mec qui
fabriquait des t-shirts dans le sens
ticket ou le piquet de harry le truc
quoi alors cette célébrité est arrivé
très vite finalement pas immédiatement
mais je crois que ça a été l'émission
qui a
le plus cartonné le plus vite c'était
vraiment une référence d'ailleurs chaque
fois qu'il y avait des soucis dans la
grille on mettait des petits bouts de
tours 5
quelle a été la réaction de votre
entourage à ce moment là pas grand chose
parce que c'était canal ce n'était pas
vraiment une quiche ltd comme les autres
tout le monde ne la recevait pas
l'époque et mes parents nice ne recevait
pas par exemple aimé et du pas mal de
mes potes ne recevait pas le nom qu'il a
fallu un peu de temps faudrait il ya une
préparation psychologique avant de me
voir vraiment à la taille avec les
médias comment ça s'est passé
plutôt pas mal babic ça marche
généralement avec les médias au début ce
qui était un petit peu troublant dans
l'histoire c'est que les premiers
articles sur canal c'était oui on va
voir parce que bon c'est fait dégommer
dès le départ malgré tout il n'y avait
pas tout le monde n'était pas là à dire
c'est une nouvelle chaîne ça va être
magnifique c'était plutôt le contraire
mais il y avait des articles qui
disaient oui alors on va voir des gens
dont on ne connaît pas les noms des marc
toesca des machins des trucs
il y avait un petit côté la droite était
très contre canadienne mitterrand way
fait du dossier n'est pas aux quatre
mois vous allez gagner de l'argent à
l'époque
non mais l'argent s'était pas on n'était
pas dans les temps un peu contrat machin
truc non premier salaire c'était 15 mini
bal de l'école voilà 2250 euros comme
engrais et sur le plan amoureux ça vous
a rapporté les conquêtes tout ça marque
belge était déjà fiancé
j'avais une petite fille quand j'ai
commencé le top 50 dont j'avais déjà une
vie relativement ranger mais j'avoue que
si j'avais voulu je me serais bien à
galets quoi mais bon quel a été le
meilleur moment de cette époque dans la
création les débuts parce que bon avant
j'étais enfin j'avais 27 ans 28 ans
quand on a créé canal donc un monde
nouveau et puis surtout c'est encore une
fois les gens qui ont créé la chaîne
il y avait une intelligence du public
une intelligence des programmes et
l'intelligence de 2 une vraie culture et
puis une vraie curiosité et quoi c'était
des mecs tu avais l'impression de
découvrir un truc connaissent l album
depuis trois ou quatre mois le dernier
film que tu as vu il avait vu lui à six
mois le dernier bouquin il avait eu un
temps à vendre
il y avait cette curiosité puis il y
avait aussi cette motivation
les mecs nous disait déconner rigoler
les gens vont déconner avec vous voilà
c'était ça et puis à l'époque c'est vrai
qu'on nous disait tant qu'ils bossent à
canal tu dois te marrer alors
qu'aujourd'hui tu bosses à canal
qu'est-ce que tu dois prendre comme tune
non mais c'est le
c'est vrai que la perception ne peut
être pas du tout la même le pire moment
de cette époque il ya un jour où j'étais
très malheureux c'est l'amant de
balavoine au mois de janvier 86
balavoine était quasiment numéro un est
bon c'est un mec que je commençais à
lacaune est très fréquentée ça a été
vraiment très difficile je parle du top
50 je parle de cette période là mais
sinon l'émission en elle même ou à la
fin ça devenait difficile parce que j'en
avais un peu marre et voilà on a décidé
de quitter le top 50 bruno solo yvan le
bolloc'h prendre la relève
c'est quoi l'usure ouais azur
c'était sept ans de tops six émissions
par semaine et puis passé il s'est passé
un truc entre 89 91 les toutes les
affaires ont disparu elles ont été
rachetés par les grands réseaux de
radios et la musique a commencé assez
uniformisée et on sentait vraiment on
revenait en été ça devenait vraiment
partout la même musique
la même chose et le top et je ressentais
ça dans le top quoi je commençais
vraiment à m'emmerder quoi sentiers plus
en phase non il y avait puis et puis à
l'épousé surprise quoi le début du top
quand regard des premiers classements un
bon il ya peter et sloane moi il ya
licence iv mais derrière il ya curie
david bowie c'est marrant mais c'est ça
ouais mais sur la fin c'était fini on
avait un jazz band jordi dur dur d'être
bébé un bébé et derrière il y avait 40
aujourd'hui quoi donc l'époque
musicalement c'était plus du tout la
même chose ne deviendrait pas chanteur
j'ai vu une tentative en 87 et de sa
gueule n'a jamais été présentée jamais
de promo vous l'avez garder un peu pour
vous se signalant ce qui s'est passé
c'est qu'à l'époque j'ai monté un studio
avec des potes et pour roder le studio
voilà on a fait on a fait ce
chef-d'oeuvre mais un clipping j'ai vu
un clic c'est vendre avec tourner un
truc pareil avec l'équipe du top 50 une
nuit on s'est dit allez on fait un clip
aux questions de s'amuser un peu et
j'étais comme un hémophile dans une
usine de lames de rasoir c'est une très
jolie forment un petit peu oui
on reviendrait pas animateur non plus
pourtant vous avez fait 4 c'est plus
avec chabat pendant trois ans
parallèlement au top 50 l'émission de
vie bricoler en trois jours pour deux
greffes qui passait l'après midi pour
les enfants passaient à 17 heures pour
les jeunes avec un angle et l'idée nous
est venue un week-end on a travaillé
avec jean louis kemp qui était
réalisateur le dimanche et le lundi dans
l'émission est à l'antenne première
invité jean jacques goldman le décor
était pas secs et quand on s'est levé on
avait tout de suite rend sa capture dans
le dos voilà c'était basse et et canal
quand c'est l'esprit canal en fête dont
vous êtes devenu ni chanteur ni
animateurs j'étais une sorte de couteau
suisse
parce qu'à l'époque en 85
j'ai couru deux fois le marathon de new
york et canal prend les droits du
marathon de new york et biétry m'appelle
et me dit tu as quand même un ton dur je
fais web deux fois l'année dernière et
l'année d'avant ouais on allait droit
donc on va faire le 2h30 de direct tu
vas partir à new york que tu vas
commenté le marathon au bon d'accord
ouais mais canal pour moi la télé c'est
ce à quoi la radio c'est pareil dire le
la possibilité de pouvoir d'aller un peu
partout de toucher un peu à tout coin ça
n'existe plus je sais c'est pour ça que
j'ai pu lier en face vous donnez
producteurs d'abord fait des
documentaires sur le sport d'ailleurs
puis des images aussi de sports extrêmes
et puis des disques produisez des
disques avec monte carlo le week end
comme un petit trait très glamour ouais
et puis le bureau aussi est très glamour
ouais mais sur la mer c'est plutôt
guerre avait dans sa bonne mais c'est
plutôt pas mal mais je pense qu'ils en
tirent alors vous avez quand même
beaucoup de mal à décoller l'étiquette
du présentateur du top 50
c'était carrément l'horreur alors oui
dans le sens où quand j'ai monté la
boîte de prod que j'avais proposé des
projets d'ehpad et les chaînes de télé
tout le monde faisait référence aux 35
ans aurait pu finir le monde et c'est
pas mal de trucs mais une émission
musicale avec un classement mais c'est
dans la tête des gens comme le seul 60
et que les gens voulaient fin le public
me voyez toujours en présentateur du top
j'ai souffert de ça au début ça m'a un
peu agacé d'ailleurs j'ai
j'ai complètement zappé la période et je
voulais plus du tout en entendre parler
et puis avec le temps voilà quoi les
stores fermés après voilà quoi au
contraire aujourd'hui je trouve ça très
attachant voilà vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque du top 50
non j'ai pas de nostalgie donc j'ai de
la tendresse quand je vois les les
images de l'époque où les photos de
l'époque j'ai beaucoup de tendresse pour
le mec chevelu avec un sourire d'ange
pis les musiques de l'époque c'est
plutôt rigolo c'était à refaire
qu'est-ce que vous ne receviez pas
pareil c'est un accident
donc j'ai pas eu la volonté de le faire
tout est arrivé un peu par hasard
voilà donc je laisserais faire le hasard
je sais pas mais voilà vraiment jeu je
sais pas peut-être que j'arrêterais
avant j'attendrai pas cette envie
d'arrêter le top 5 oui je pense que le
jeu vous allez mourir cassoulet qu'on
remarque sur votre tombe comme jésus sur
la croix
salut les p'tits clous c'est bon ça
c'est très heureux de cet intérêt est
que l'on est sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu